- But last time, you and
your brothers mentioned
that you were working on new music.
So asking for a friend, how's that going?
When am I gonna get some new music?
- We're usually like
really cryptic about this.
And I just kind of feel
like that's really stupid.
I don't know why we do that.
- Yeah.
- So we're working on new music for sure.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- And I can tell you-
(crowd cheers)
- [Kelly] I'm excited,
I love y'alls music.
- I can tell you that I think it's
my favorite stuff we've ever done.
And it's basically
an evolution of the sound
in a way that I think
is really natural for us
and feels like a great next step.
And we're working with some people
we've always wanted to work with.
And I can't wait for everyone to hear it.
(crowd cheers)
- I know, I said this last
time that y'all were here
but I loved your show.
Like I had never been able to
like really watch a full show.
And it's so interesting cause
we would be on The Voice
and you forget.
Like you're sitting next to like,
I'm like oh, you're super talented.
You just forget cause
you're all just hanging out.
And I was at your show and
I was like, holy I know him.
I was like, I was like, I was like,
it was just, we can't say
that on daytime, but whatever.
But I was just freaking out
because y'all were so good.
It was the songs were so
good, the energy was so good.
- Thanks a lot.
- [Kelly] The crowd Like loved it.
And I loved the fact that
the crowd was like totally
all different walks of life.
Like all different time.
That's my favorite kind
of crowd where you're like
nowhere would you find these people.
That's my favorite kind of musical crowd.
- I agree with you.
- [Kelly] Cause I feel
like music can do that.
Like bring randos together.
- Absolutely can.
And I feel like the fun thing
in this last couple years
specifically has been
that we've really seen
that distinction of,
beyond the kind of OG fans
who've been there forever,
to a lot of the older people
who have come to our shows,
perhaps watched The Voice or other things.
And then younger people
who were introduced to us
in the last couple years
and think we're a new band.
It's like this-
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- It's like, oh yeah.
- People think you're a new band?
That's my favorite thing that people do.
Like if I perform
somewhere and they're like
oh my gosh, you can sing.
And I'm like, well.
Well a little.
And I'm like, but it is
my favorite thing cause
you know that person, no,
they didn't mean offense,
they just hadn't really heard anything.
And I'm like, okay, well thank you.